[Música]
bueno muy buenos días muchas gracias
venimos a hablar de revolucionarios
los humanos quiero que nos define como
humanos hay quien dice que lo que nos
define como humanos es la tecnología o
el lenguaje lo que de verdad nos define
como humanos es que somos
revolucionarios
la verdadera característica de los
humanos es nuestra capacidad de cambiar
de una manera contundente y cambiar de
modelo los humanos somos los que somos
capaces de cambiar de modelo somos los
los humanos somos los revolucionarios
esa es la verdadera característica que
nos define como humanos otra
característica de la palabra revolución
revolución nos hace humanos pero otra
característica
revolución implica lucha
revolución implica cambiar de un modelo
sin que sea amable revolución significa
forzar la máquina para cambiar el modelo
una revolución no es un cambio amable
una revolución es un cambio de lucha lo
que nos hace humanos es querer cambiar
lo que nos hace revolucionarios es estar
dispuestos a luchar por poder cambiar
así que ser revolucionario es y luchar
por el cambio
pero cambiar nunca es fácil cambiar es
incómodo cambiar implica un esfuerzo
cambiar es salir de la zona de confort y
si encima le añades lucha cambiar es un
conflicto ser revolucionario es un
conflicto y a los conflictos normalmente
nos referimos con palabras más
sofisticadas eso de decir quiero cambiar
la gente me dice pensado cambiar el otro
día hubo un cambio la palabra cambio la
reservamos para las cosas ha pasado de
frío a caliente pero los humanos
preferimos cambiar el lenguaje si
revolucionario es sinónimo de un cambio
con lucha necesitamos añadirle
connotaciones a eso y en la palabra a la
palabra cambio le metemos connotaciones
que quiere decir
revolucionario en el fondo que tienes
connotaciones positivas cuando tú dices
que una cosa es revolucionaria es porque
te la miras con ganas de que esto sea
bueno si creyeras que esto va a ser malo
la llamaría es crisis
decimos revolución tecnológica porque en
el fondo tenemos la esperanza de que va
a ir mejor pero decimos crisis climática
porque creemos que en el fondo va a ir
peor dirías revolución climática si
fueras optimista y dirías crisis
tecnológica si fueras pesimista cuando
tú dices
revolucionario quiere decir en el fondo
que haces una lucha para conseguir
cambios que crees que serán a mejor
o menos lo que eres tú porque en el
fondo eso depende de qué depende de
según como lo mires todo depende
en la revolución francesa
a la revolución francesa alguien creyó
que se iba a ir mejor estás de acuerdo
fue mejor fue peor la revolución
industrial alguien creía que eso iba a
ir mejor estáis de acuerdo alguien dice
que la revolución industrial es del
problema de el causante de los problemas
en los que estamos ahora otros creen que
la revolución industrial fue un progreso
progreso otra palabra muy interesante
nadie ha dicho nunca que el progreso sea
positivo si coges un diccionario
progreso solo implica cambio el progreso
de una situación de un estado a otro
estado somos nosotros que le damos
connotaciones positivas a todo esto así
que cuando decimos
revolución implica una lucha por
conseguir cambios estructurales
interpretada con optimismo esa es la
descripción que os propongo de la
palabra revolución
vamos a ir avanzando hacia la revolución
que nos ocupa hasta ahora
cuántas revoluciones hemos tenido en la
historia de la humanidad
cuántas
cuántos cambios estructurales hemos
tenido en la historia de la humanidad si
coges el concepto de historia de la
humanidad con
con un cierto una mirada una perspectiva
un poco amplia las etapas de la historia
son básicamente paleolítico neolítico
mundo clásico una cierta transición de
barbarie hasta llegar la edad media y
después de la media la historia moderna
y luego la historia contemporánea
cuantas más salido 6
es correcto distribuir la historia de
los humanos en solo seis períodos
preferís que sean 7-8 pero fijaos la
macro historia se escribe con 56 grandes
etapas tu puedes por ejemplo la
historia contemporánea y empezar a
especificar primera guerra mundial entre
guerra segunda guerra mundial guerra
fría y empezar a hacer zoom pero los
cambios estructurales de la historia de
los humanos al final te salen seis o
siete grandes etapas paleolítico
neolítico que tienen en común esas seis
o siete etapas que en la transición de
una a otra claramente estamos en una
revolución no estamos en una revolución
en la transición de entreguerras no sé
que las grandes etapas de la historia
son globales las grandes revoluciones de
la humanidad son globales
el paso de paleolítico neolítico lo
distingue entre china y europa en cambio
el cambio de primera segunda guerra
mundial se distingue por zonas y por y
por países en colombia cuando les hablas
de la transición de primera segunda
guerra mundial no están leyendo lo mismo
que nosotros incluso podrías hacer zoom
en la historia de españa' aparece la
guerra civil y otros períodos que en la
historia de finlandia no aparecen cuando
tú te vas a los elementos macro de la
historia transición de paleolítico
neolítico siempre hay revoluciones y
quiero hablar de esas revoluciones vais
a ver en el paralítico por ejemplo en el
paleolítico hay una revolución es que
por primera vez los humanos son capaces
de la naturaleza y modificarla
para sus intereses en el paleolítico
desarrollamos por primera vez la
tecnología la tecnología es
modificar la naturaleza
para sobrevivir mejor coges una piedra y
la modificación una punta de flecha es
revolucionario coges una piedra y la
modificación una herramienta ahora nos
parecerá muy básico pero esto es un hito
y un marxista te diría que de ahí
aparece la especialización en el trabajo
hasta entonces sólo sobrevivían los que
eran capaces de cazar y ser fuertes y
cuando aparece esta tecnología un cojo
podría ser capaz de sobrevivir porque él
hace las puntas de flecha y otro caza
con esas puntas de flecha y se han
repartido el trabajo una visión existe
un poco marxista eh pero que tienen en
común las revoluciones de la historia de
la humanidad que aparece una tecnología
que modifica el contrato social
cuando te vas al neolítico si en el
paralítico modificamos nuestra relación
con la naturaleza en el palais en el
neolítico modificamos nuestra relación
con el espacio eramos nómadas
persiguiendo a los rebaños para poder
comer y alimentarnos y de repente
aprendemos con tecnología que podemos
domesticar a las especies la agricultura
la ganadería son tecnologías y con esa
tecnología cambiamos otra página del
contrato social ya no solo nos
repartimos el trabajo ahora además vamos
a repartirnos el espacio cuando el único
en el neolítico los humanos tienen por
primera vez la necesidad de pactar el
orden del espacio
por ejemplo tú tienes un poblado y de la
cabaña del centro grandota donde le da
al sol para quien será en unas
sociedades
más bonitas para nuestro gusto se
decidió que ese espacio del centro de
donde toca al sol y está protegido iba a
ser un espacio comunitario para todos
pero en otras sociedades más
autoritarias se decidió que la cabaña
del centro sería para mí pero porque
para mí si quieres te lo explico pero no
te va a gustar
se desarrollan modelos autoritarios y
fruto de la discusión social sobre cómo
se reparte el espacio surgen surgen
grupos humanos que se organizan de una u
otra manera en el paleolítico tenemos
una tecnología que modifica la relación
con la naturaleza y cambian las
relaciones en el grupo en el neolítico
tenemos una tecnología que cambia las
relaciones con el espacio y se modifican
las relaciones en el grupo y así las
distintas revoluciones que enmarcan el
carácter la evolución de la historia de
la humanidad
en la revolución industrial aparece una
tecnología muy evidente el vapor la
electricidad del motor de explosión
etcétera que provoca un cambio en el
contrato social y es que de repente la
sociedad se organiza alrededor del
trabajo ya no de el espacio con el común
el neolítico es uno del trabajo en la
sociedad industrial
a construimos un nuevo contrato basado
en el trabajo el trabajo es lo que te
define lo que te explica antes de la
revolución industrial dow era tan
evidente y además el trabajo se masifica
hay veinte mil tres personas trabajando
en una misma compañía antes eran cinco
artesanos trabajando en un taller de
repente tenemos empresas en las que
trabajan 50.000 personas 100.000
personas
150.000 personas y hay que
industrializar las relaciones laborales
y todo este capítulo de relaciones
laborales no estaba pactado y no estaba
consensuado de la misma manera que en el
neolítico no estaba pactado y
consensuado la relación con el espacio
en la revolución industrial pactamos la
relación con el trabajo y de entrada eso
no estaba nada claro y como es una
revolución hay una lucha y como es una
lucha hay dos bandos depende según cómo
se mire
en la revolución industrial hay quien
dice que hay que empezar a discutir la
jornada laboral el derecho a la baja
laboral la defensa contra un despido
improcedente el derecho a la jubilación
el derecho a las condiciones laborales
dignas el trabajo infantil que mujeres y
hombres cobren lo mismo la duración de
la jornada laboral todo eso no estaba
discutido y hubo que discutirlo y fue en
conflicto la primera vez que alguien se
dirigió a su empresa y le dijo estábamos
aquí fuera y hemos pensado que quizás
sería mejor hacer jornadas de 8 horas y
un día de fiesta la semana y ya que
estamos un mes de vacaciones al año la
contraparte no le dijo oye pues muy bien
pensado para que lo dices mucho mejor si
lo hacemos así eso no fue así eso fue en
conflicto y duró generaciones
esa es la tendencia de las revoluciones
humanas se genera un conflicto una lucha
que modifica el contrato social y unos
lo viven con
la percepción de que se va a ser un
progreso
el resultado es una modificación del
contrato social hoy el pasaporte social
es el trabajo en casa te preguntan que
cómo va el trabajo
cuando te presentas y tuve que trabajar
cuando pides un préstamo para intentar
alquilar un piso sin un contrato de
trabajo el contrato de trabajo es la
garantía de que puedes merecer te
alquilar un piso intentaban pedir una
hipoteca o un préstamo sin un contrato
de trabajo el contrato de trabajo es el
pasaporte social el contrato de trabajo
el contrato de trabajo es lo que ha
ordenado nuestras vidas desde la
revolución industrial hasta hoy
todo este preámbulo es para explicaros
que estamos en una de esas revoluciones
que marcan la historia de los humanos y
de las que sólo hemos tenido cinco o
seis o siete y estamos en plena
revolución digital
estamos en el momento en que hay una
tecnología
que modifica algo esencial de las
relaciones humanas esta vez no estamos
modificando la relación con el espacio o
la relación con el trabajo fijaos que
son cosas muy básicas esta vez estamos
modificando nuestra relación con la
información
estamos definiendo de quién es la
información si la información es buena o
mala quién tiene derecho a utilizar la
información antes discutíamos quién
tenía derecho a utilizar la cabaña del
centro del poblado y ahora estamos
discutiendo quién tiene derecho a
utilizar todo el volumen de información
de cada uno de nosotros y en esa
discusión no está nada claro de la misma
manera que en el siglo 18 no estaba
claro
y la jornada laboral podría ser de 14
horas ahora no está nada claro si
alguien puede utilizar 14 datos tuyos 24
datos tuyos 120 datos tuyos
empieza a no estar claro si la
información es fiable o no es fiable 6
fake o no space como castigamos en el
grupo a alguien que emite información
falsa como castigamos en el grupo a
alguien que utiliza información que no
debería estar utilizando como premiamos
en el grupo a alguien que hace un uso
riguroso y escrupuloso de la información
en la revolución industrial construimos
un contrato social alrededor de la del
trabajo en la sociedad digital
construiremos un contrato social
alrededor de la información y estamos en
eso y va a ser largo en la revolución
industrial la revolución industrial
cógela viquipèdia empezó en el siglo 18
en el siglo 18 empezamos la discusión
sobre cómo sería una sociedad organizada
alrededor del trabajo y aún hoy siglo 21
un cuarto de siglo veintiuno ya aún
estamos discutiendo si los globos son
riders o son autónomos o qué narices
pasa con sus derechos laborales
250 años después aún tenemos detalles de
una sociedad basada en el trabajo
pendientes de resolver si la sociedad
industrial tardo 250 años en
desarrollarse y ha sido la más reciente
y más rápida de la historia cuánto
tiempo tardará la sociedad digital en
desarrollarse mi teoría es que si la
sociedad digital fuera la de desarrollo
más vertiginoso de la historia de la
humanidad puede que alargamos en apenas
100 años
y para desarrollar esta sociedad en
apenas 100 años faltan 70 porque todavía
llevamos apenas hace 30 años que hemos
empezado estamos en 2021 la primera vez
que un particular se conectó a internet
desde su hogar
libremente por ejemplo aquí en españa
antes de 1994 solo se conectaban a
internet desde centros de investigación
universidades o laboratorios la primera
vez que un particular desde su casa pudo
contratar acceso a internet fue finales
del año 94 y el que lo hizo la persona
que lo hizo fue alguien
fuera de la norma eran unos pocos lo que
hacían esto si quieres mirar cuando se
normalizó que la sociedad accediera a
internet tienes que entrar ya en el
siglo 21 te tienes que meter ya en el
año 2000 2001 2002
fijaos yo tengo 55 años no tiene el 66
me casé a los 30 tengo dos hijos una
hija y un hijo que nacieron cuando yo
tenía 31 y 33 años
yo estaba casado y con dos hijos y no
existía google
mirarlo como queráis la sociedad digital
acaba de empezar aún estamos
desarrollando las primeras
infraestructuras aún estamos poniendo
sensores en las cosas aún estamos
descubriendo nuevas capacidades de
generar ráfagas de datos aún estamos
montando el cableado de lo que tiene que
ser una sociedad digital apenas llevamos
20-25 años
bastante acelerado si queréis pero
apenas llevamos 20 ó 25 años faltan 70
75 y con esto voy concluyendo
somos la primera generación
de la revolución digital
le hemos llamado revolución porque
tenemos la esperanza de que sea para
algo mejor pero no está claro podría ser
una crisis digital pero le llamamos
revolución porque tenemos esperanza
si alguno de vosotros tiene por ejemplo
25 años
no vais a vivir lo suficiente para ver
esta sociedad digital
desarrollada e implementada todos
vosotros y puede que la siguiente
generación vais a vivir la transición
hacia una sociedad digital
somos sois los protagonistas de influir
y contribuir a cómo será eso y por lo
tanto como en toda buena revolución o se
ha tocado celebrando vivir una época de
lucha en la revolución industrial hubo
quien luchó por los derechos de los
trabajadores a vosotros les tocará
luchar por los derechos de la
información y depende de vuestra lucha
si estos derechos van a ser dignos o van
a ser patéticos en la medida que sean
dignos estoy convencido de que podemos
tener una sociedad mejor en la medida
que sean patéticos esto va a ser un
desastre así que
porque los próximos 50 a 60 años vais a
estar muy ocupados discutiendo un nuevo
capítulo del contrato social de la
humanidad en la hacéis con una tradición
que empezó hace 250.000 años
sois protagonistas de una revolución que
modifica el grupo cuáles son las
características de una revolución
aparece una tecnología disruptiva
se discute el contrato social
el tamaño del grupo a gestionar cambia
después de una revolución el tamaño del
grupo siempre es más grande ahora
estamos en crisis del estado-nación no
tiene el tamaño suficiente para defender
al grupo porque las las propuestas son
globales el tamaño mínimo puede que sea
continental venimos de las ciudades de
estado de los estados nación y se nos ha
quedado pequeño por lo tanto tecnología
disruptiva nuevo contrato social
tamaño del grupo más ampliado lucha por
los derechos
lucha por los derechos
y a disfrutar que son dos días espero
que os haya parecido interesante
[Aplausos]